-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
I'm here with Tariq Trotter
from the Roots!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we're about to play
a game of "Catchphrase,"
but we need some partners.
Joining my team,
he is starring in
"When You Finish
Saving the World,"
in theaters everywhere
January 20th.
Please give it up
for Finn Wolfhard!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's my man!
That's what I'm talking about.
Tariq, your partner stars in
the hit show "The White Lotus,"
with all episodes available
on HBO Max.
Please welcome Meghann Fahy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How you doing?
-Hi!
-Yes, let's do this.
-Okay.
-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
-Hi, hi, hi.
-Here's how the game works.
Okay?
I'm gonna start the round by
pressing start on this buzzer,
and then, Meghann, you will draw
a clue from the top of the pile.
-Okay.
-You have to get your partner
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible
and then hand the buzzer
to the person on your right.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team lose that round.
-Okay.
This is going to be a disaster.
-No, what are you talking about?
We're partners.
-No, no. Sorry.
-With an attitude like that.
-Sorry.
I don't -- I'm kind of -- Yeah.
Looking into the future.
-Finn, you go there.
Me and you got this. Come on.
-I believe in you, Finn.
-Meghann, you're here.
Tariq, you're over there.
Finn, you're there.
-Okay.
-So, I'll press start,
then you --
I'll give it to you,
then you pick the clue.
Then we start the game.
-Okay.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-And here we go.
[ Beeping ]
-Okay.
It's a thing
that everybody does.
-Instagram. TikTok.
-No, it's, like, at the
beginning of a new thing...
-Make a New Year's resolution.
-Yes.
-Whoa! Great. Alright. Good.
That's great. Perfect.
-It's me now?
-Okay. It's a new movie.
There's a dancing doll
that dances.
-"M3GAN."
-Yeah.
-You eat this thing.
It comes on a bun.
-A hot dog.
-Yes.
-You put this together.
It's a bunch of furniture.
It's like Flugen
with the Blugen Blergen.
-Ikea?
-Yes, Ikea, yes.
-Whoa! Wow. Impressive. Okay.
Oh, they just canceled, like,
a bunch of flights
and everybody was really sad.
-Southwest.
-Yes.
-Uh...
-Lollipop!
-Yes.
-You wear this on your hands.
It's like hand paint.
-Hand paint?
-Yeah, put you put it
on your fingertips.
-Nail polish.
-Yes.
-Uh, uh --
-[ Buzzer ]
--Coffee, but it's --
-Ahh!
-See? We got this.
-You know -- those poor Swedes
that you were just like --
You were just like,
"Uh, Flugen store."
And I was like,
"Sweden! Sweden! Sweden!"
-"Ikea!" You got it.
Yeah, of course.
That's what it kind of is.
I don't know how to -- Gosh.
That last one was cold brew.
-Oh.
I would have said frappuccino.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you're right.
It is a cold brew.
I was going to say
coffee but not hot.
-Yes, yes.
Well, you said coffee, and I was
about to say frappuccino.
-Really? Alright. Good. Perfect.
Alright. We got this.
So it's 1-zip.
Congratulations.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-Alright. Here we go.
I'm gonna start this one off.
Ready, bud?
-Yep.
-[ Beeping ]
-When there's a celebration,
they pop this --
-Confetti.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
I would have said champagne.
Oh, Tom Cruise.
They just did a new one.
-"Top Gun."
-Yes.
-Okay.
When you win an award
you give a...
-Speech. Acceptance speech.
-Yes.
-Um, this is --
You know, it's -- it's a --
-Hurry up!
-The president of Russia with
an "E" at the end of his name.
-Oh, my God! What?!
-Who runs Russia?
-I'm -- I'm panicking.
Can we skip it?
-Skip, skip.
-Poutine, poutine, poutine!
-Yes, yes!
-Sorry! I'm sorry!
-Dancing? Elvis.
-Yes.
-Um, uh,
I don't know what to say.
[ Buzzer ]
-It's okay. We're tied.
We're tied. We're tied.
-Sorry about that.
-Tied game.
-No, you got it.
-What was it? What was it?
-Could have said fries.
-I could have. I could have.
-Oh, a hole punch.
-Alright.
We're going to play
one more round, alright?
This one is worth 10,000 points,
so it's anyone's game.
-Okay.
-Since when was that
a rule of catchphrase?
-It's a new rule.
It's a new rule.
Here we go. Oh, my gosh.
Alright. Here we go.
You can start us off, Meghann.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-[ Beeping ]
-Um, uh, uh, it's a --
it's a network that does
a lot of home renovations.
-The Home -- DIY Network?
-No. It's letters.
It's not really a word.
It's like a few letters.
And it's -- I don't think
I can say what it is.
-HN -- HN -- H--
The Home --
-You grow flowers in a...
-In a pot?
-No. In a...
-In a garden!
The Gardening Network.
HGN. HGN.
-Yes! Well, no.
-Ohh! HNG? Home Garden--
-Yes.
-Home Gardening Network.
-No!
-Home and Garden.
Better Home and Garden.
Better homes and Gardens.
-No.
-Better Homes and Gardens?
-I don't know! Pass.
-Let's give it to him.
-[ Buzzer ]
-Come on, bud.
-I'm sorry.
-That was perfect.
-You know what's crazy?
Your entire band doubted you,
so they started playing, like,
a jazz song to embarrass you.
-HGTV.
-Aah! HGTV!
-So close!
My thanks to Finn Wolfhard,
Meghann Fahy, Tariq Trotter.
We're talking to Finn
after the break. [ Laughs ]